[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to trigonometric I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is to show if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
and a fascinating guest we have for you
today he is a superstar Irish economist
broadcaster he just told us he's the
host of the number one podcast in
Ireland David McWilliams welcome to
trigonometry Constantin thank you very
much for having me and Francis it's
great to be here what's the craic boys
he enjoined the lockup
I am Francis not so much he's stuck
completely on his own in a flat in
London and that's why he looks
increasingly more and more like my
grandmother you know I also your
grandmother was very attractive lady
I'll tell her you said that Dave if you
want to morph into you know an
attractive grinder all in Ukraine
Ukraine yes there's a career ahead of
you I'm sure absolutely is 2020 I can be
whatever I want exactly exactly exactly
exactly it's fantastic to have you this
cups of tea no nami you go for it we've
got one here with the chicken on Bradway
of course but it's been a long time in
the making this interview so is a
pleasure to have you on and what a time
to have the conversation I mean
obviously very very uncertain times very
significant times as well what do you
make of what's happening now and
particularly the economic impact of the
lockdowns that we've seen around the
West is this the beginning of a Great
Depression Jim Rickards who you will
know from the festival that you
co-organized kill Kannamma --xe we had
him on the show a couple of weeks ago
and he said we're already in a great
depression what what is your reading of
things well well I think I think a
cubist Jim is right if you decide that a
great depression is measured by GDP
Falls unemployment fiscal deficits all
that sort of stuff very clear that we're
in Great Depression territory in terms
of what's going on right now the
question is whether or not the Great
Depression materializes the Great
Depression was a
36-month affair it would do it over
three years started in about 1931-32 the
interesting thing is it didn't start
directly after the Wall Street Crash it
took a couple of years to materialize
and it went on until the Americans broke
with the gold standard and started
printing money which is probably the
opposite of what Jim would recommend the
the the solution so I would say that we
are if we don't fix the next couple of
months there is a very chance that
there'll be these these IDs these things
these long tails like talk in economics
but in actual fact the economy will
continue to weaken however the problem
at the moment is really a lack of money
it's a cash flow problem that most small
businesses big businesses are quite okay
but most small businesses are running
out of money simply because the trust in
the system has broken so for example if
you run a small business and you have
credit lines with your creditors and
that's a they are 90 days in good times
when everything's normal so you send out
your invoices you actually use your
invoices as is invoice discounting so
invoices in a non panic situation are
actually as good as cash so you go to
the bank with your invoices you say that
these guys owe me ten grand or a hundred
grand will you give me cash against that
the cashes yeah and this'll give you 70
grand
so invoice discounting is a way in which
small companies manage cash flow in
normal times and recently folks and
small companies lancers that small
companies are actually who employ the
vast vast majority of people this
obsession with Google and Facebook and
all these big companies but the big oil
companies which I'm sure we'll talk
about there they were big they're
getting smaller I suspect they'll be
very small by the end of this afternoon
the point is that so let's talk about
the who I would regard as the wheel
heroes of the economy the small business
so let's come back so in the cash flow
problem most small businesses don't have
a big pool of cash they don't have
investors that are generous they
certainly haven't been able to ride that
stock market chair bonanza over the last
seven or eight years and turned this
talking to cash so they're they're very
much week to week month to month players
and something like this really shocks
them and what happens in the situation
at this is that the trust dissipates so
you don't trust the guy but it's
basically you fear that they are going
to run out of cash in the same way
you're running out of cash so basically
all credit lines are truncated to these
with 90 days they truncate until it's 10
days so any rollover finance which is
again what all small businesses need and
they use each other as banks that's the
interesting thing small businesses don't
go to the banks and state can I have a
10-grand overdraft what they say is I'm
dealing with this guy be doing for 10
years I'll use his invoice or his cash
flow to bolster my cash flow and that
starts to atrophy as it's doing right
now what you find is small businesses
good businesses go out of business
because of a lack of money which is
probably the least reasonable way in
which a small business can go out of
money the problem with the lack of money
if there's a lack of money you just
print it okay so what I believe has to
be done now is something that economists
called helicopter money which comes
after Milton Friedman's idea that you
basically drop money out of the
helicopter it's like you've ever seen
the beginning of Apocalypse Now I've
ever seen that helicopters committee
imagine that except they're dropping
money not napalm so it's a whole
different experience bit of vogner as
well it's always good you know but I
think that's gonna happen I think that
has to happen I think that's the only
way because it's a very simple thing
that's going on here
it's two things so it's number one we
have to make sure that small businesses
don't collapse okay and that they exist
when we come out of the lockdown that's
the first thing second thing is we've
got to ensure that all the government
spending that's going on now doesn't
lead to austerity and by that I mean it
doesn't lead to a massive increase in
the debt GDP ratio push up debt
servicing costs and prompt austerity two
or three years down the road so the last
thing we want is economies hit by kovat
and just about recovering and then hit
again by austerity and the way
would you do that is the central bank
pays for everything this sounds like
magic because it kind of is if I speak
as a former central bank economist
that's my training and I was very very
much part of the inside and that in my
in my youth many many years ago that the
awesome power of central banking is the
following that they just print money
they make it up there's no balance sheet
there's no gold there's nothing they
need against it they print money that is
why central banks are so powerful and
twice for hundreds of years one of the
key battlegrounds in all politics and
all kingdoms and or princelings in all
fledgling democracies is who prints the
money and you probably should have
realized it was something up in Cuba
when they made Che Guevara
their first central bank governor after
the Revolution that was clearly the
signal to sell if you could get out of
the place but the point is this isn't
whoeverís prints the money has got the
most power right and the power vested in
the Bank of England the Federal Reserve
the ECB Bank of Japan is phenomenal and
it's right now that we have to what I
would just say is turn right on the tops
now at the moment the Bank of England
and the ECB and whatever are playing
around with this what I've called Barnes
jiggery-pokery so what they're saying is
yes we will give you lots and lots of
money but basically it has to go through
the banking system and in the banking
system acts is the middleman and the
middleman then gets it to you that
demands that the small business that
we're talking about has to go to the
bank in the first place as to fill out a
form and to look for a grant has to give
the bank you know five or six years of
back profits etc big balance sheets as
to wait has to get me rated zero it's
too long so my solution is very very
simple not just my solution actually
Milton Friedman came up with basically
just you just credit the bank accounts
of small business with a zero or maybe
two zeros at the end and what this does
is it most importantly dissipates the
fear that we've got a default on each
other then the system begins to easily
breathe again and though
cruise lines that we were truncated and
were actually screaming bankruptcy they
go back at two months three months four
months and we rest easy in the lockdown
and then we wait for the doctors to tell
us what time we should come come out
whether it's next month or the month
after water so to answer your question I
don't see a great depression unless of
course the authorities are profoundly
unimaginative and they stick to what
they're doing at the moment they have to
do a hell of a lot more very quickly it
can be done I think we're moving in that
direction and let's see what happens in
the next couple of weeks
Francis before you jump in let me just
ask follow up on this and then you go
ahead because you have lots of things
you want to toss David about as well but
David if I'm one of the great things
about you is you're very good at
explaining comics to people who are
economists right but if I'm an ordinary
person and I'm listening to what you're
saying which I am an ordinary person
listening my point is I don't have the
economic understanding and knowledge
that you do right but what I'm hearing
is well we're gonna create money now if
I'm an ordinary person I'm going well
that I don't know how I don't know when
I don't know where but surely that has
some negative impact somewhere we
otherwise we'd be doing it all the time
surely well this is the Barry it's a
very very good question right the reason
central bankers are regarded as the most
conservative people in the economic
Savannah let us say okay and again as I
say I worked in one for quite a while is
because they build up credibility about
fighting inflation that's the thing we
will not let inflation take over and the
reason you build up credibility about
not fighting about fighting inflation is
when you're faced with deflation which
we're faced down where prices are
falling you actually can unleash this
awesome power of people believe that you
will do the right thing so that's why
central banks are very important in the
wrong hands
at the wrong time a central bank can
destroy a country by destroying the
currency you saw that in Zimbabwe for
example Central Bank of Zimbabwe
destroyed the currency so much so that
the
little bottle of coke became the unit of
account in Zimbabwe during the
hyperinflation right so in the wrong
hands at the wrong time the central bank
can destroy the country in the right
hands at the right heart time central
bank can save the country by doing
exactly this which is by creating money
one of the great myths of economics is
that money has value it has only value
in its social context and people
actually believe it right which is why
for example if I take five euros out of
my pockets which has no intrinsic value
there's no intrinsic value in the piece
of paper the value is only that I
believe that they can buy me two cups of
coffee right that is a a mind game that
we play with each other and so the
essential thing about money is that it
has no real value other than the value
that we ascribe to it and that value
comes from our knowledge that the
central bank won't print too much of it
in normal times so there won't be too
much of it around but so that is answer
first part of your question second part
of your question is then do you have to
mop this money up later on because it's
still in the system and the system yes
you do and that's it you do that other
thing called open market operations
where the central bank just comes in and
usually tops the banking system the
shoulders a listen Meishan give us that
cash that's sitting idle in your account
so the bank says fair enough you're
gonna pay us you said yeah we pay a bit
of interest thanks is fine okay you have
that's how it works it's called
open market operations it's a trade John
at the end of every day you can do that
very very easily and the third issue is
then if you aren't worried about
inflation if this can be done why don't
we do it all the time okay what is it
all happen and that again is the
credibility that we vest in the
institution's it's a bit like saying to
an army if you like killing people why
don't you do it all the time you know
because that's what they do right and we
decide that our ministries of Defense
are a sufficiently trustworthy but they
don't send fellows out killing it all
the time you do realize you talk into a
Russian divers in in Russia you have
entirely different
but you see what I mean you know that
there are many many extraordinary powers
that can be unleashed by a democratic
government not least its own military
its police force for example here in
Ireland but I love about Irish cops is
they don't Irish cops are great I've
been watching them for the last couple
of days they don't police the country
they negotiate with the country it's so
nice you know like you've got fellas out
drinking pretending and all because our
lockdown is that basically we can't go
more than 2 kilometers from our house I
mean we can only be with people in the
house so you look at fellas on the pier
down beside me we clearly do not live
with each other and have been I've found
each other in that beautiful way that
alcoholics find each other
found peers and open spaces and the cops
rather than they been heavy adamant and
just negotiates in to come on let's be
reasonable
what a man so what I'm saying is there
is an awesome power that democratic
countries can unleash upon the people
central banking is one of those and as
along as long as that power is not
abused
it's very credible and then when you
have to do it you do it and David I was
reading one of your articles in which
you were talking about one of the silver
linings of this crisis because obviously
there's plenty of negatives but there
will be positives that emerge in
particularly you believe that we are
going to create a population that is
more socially aware absolutely do you
still believe that yeah I think but I
think that the soft issues of economics
are much more interesting than the hard
ones so balance of payments inflation
exchange rates the idea that's very
simple stuff well what's really
interesting as a soft ideas of
sociability trust credibility what they
what they call the social fabric social
capital and social capital is based on
having a very strong sense of community
so if you contrast for example the
reaction of northern European countries
I don't include the UK and data suitcase
is slight outlier nobody joke but there
has been we left may we last party so
Wrigley's brexit sex it means per exit
it's great that brexit has not been
spoken about as well which is yeah oh
what a release mate yeah no I think so
what you see is that the the crisis you
know this this expression the where you
hear all the time in the health service
switches that a hundred people died
today but X amount of them had
underlying issues underlying health
problems underline and conditions they
call us right I think that they the
crisis any crisis reveals a hell of a
lot about societies actually if they're
one of the more interesting things about
crisis is what it tells you about the
state of the country and the difference
between let's say the United States
switch and under northwest Europe has
been quite profound and it's the
following is that the United States in
the same way as in a patient who has
underlying conditions is more fragile in
the face of the pandemic a country that
has underlying conditions those
conditions are exposed in the pandemic
so what you see in northwest Europe is
social solidarity a belief in science
and belief in the government and
understanding the police force and the
medics working together are actually
working in our favor and they believe in
what's called in economics the paradox
of aggregation which is basically what
is good for the individual is not always
good for the collective so basically if
the collective say we should all stay in
then we stay in even though it
subjugates
individual rights to the extent that we
believe that we happen in the united
states i think what you've seen is an
exposure of these underlying conditions
so the death rate is much higher much
higher amongst poor people why because
the infrastructure isn't there the
public hospitals aren't there the
president has regarding the entire thing
as already seen the whole entire thing
through his own personal lens how do i
Donald Trump play out this he has the
governor's bidding for PPE equipment
against each other
inequality is exposing the fact that
poor people are dying in much greater
numbers you know I could go on but my
sense is that
the social solidarity that has been
evidenced is very very significant other
change of the world so I'll give you an
example in 1945 in the United Kingdom
and Britain wins the second world war
okay with with the Allies of course I
mean the idea that the Brits won the
second Wars for me complete palabra
constant stinks people won the Second
World War the Second World War and then
the English speakers came in at the far
side and you know what a life free with
my point is let's go back to mmm had you
said on the eve of the surrender of
Hitler when Churchill is beast riding
the globe and as a Alton he's talking to
Roosevelt and Stalin and etc the
Churchill would have been defeated in
the next general election you've said no
way that's not possible
well what how could happen in the Second
World War was the trauma of the war and
the social contract and the
extraordinary coming together of the
people in the Second World War changed
profoundly the way they looked at the
world so suddenly they said actually
let's have a National Health Service
let's have a free education let's have a
national distant the other the soldiers
coming back from the front said no no no
we're not going back to the same we're
not going back to you know tops running
the place as was the case after the
first world war we're actually going to
book change the country so you know
Churchill gets kicked out it's amazing
less than 12 months after he wins the
second world war and what is replaced by
is a reflection of the national
solidarity in policy which was a Labour
government I'm just doing this for our
UK viewers because you know it's it's
important to see things for the UK
perspective that's one example you'd
think after the Spanish flu for example
in the United States the 1920s is
without a doubt the most technologically
and financially sophisticated
cage in most of the 20th century you get
think about what happened the Americans
respond to this drama by extraordinary
technological innovation electricity
radios teller grounds telephones cars
all the sort of stuff so my sense is
that there is a way to look at this
Frances which is that the social glue
the social capital that has been become
more adhesive in the crisis could be
used as a platform of which to change
society's for the better and do you
think that the youth can become a
vanguard for change because they're the
ones as far as we know at this point who
are least affected by the virus so you
were proposing that actually they should
be the ones at the vanguard of
reinvigorates in the economy starting
everything up and let's get some
youthful energy changing lowering our
economies Francis did the least affected
by the virus but most affected by the
chaton that's so like everything you
should see through Jenner and generation
law you should you could you can see the
world through these generational lenses
and I remember years ago interviewing
Tony Benn remember Tony bandy oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah and I was presenting a
show here in Ireland after my central
banking days for me when I went rogue
and abandoned sort of conservative
economics and when I was doing media and
all and I was I was interviewing Tony
bear in his house in Holland Park and he
used to do all his research from this
quite dusty quite an actual fact he
looked he would be a perfect person for
the webcam era because the back was
always full of books you know first as I
said we prepare the Fallujah I've just
been captured by Isis yeah
but whereas Tony Benn was very much the
few imagined The Economist as who I'm
going to and use a 10 now I better put
of all my books behind me so afraid
clever
well Tony Benn mostly that's the
difference and but he said something
about generations he said DISA
I was into music young man
you would I have something in common and
I said what's this and I looked younger
than my age at the time and he said he
said he said the young and the old have
one thing in common I said what's that
this is were [ __ ] bullied by the
middle-aged I thought it was a really
good expression to me explain the way
the world works so if you look at any
generational thing the youth in Ireland
where we've run the numbers Arnold as a
population about five million of which
about 1.4 million are under the age of
35 they should be released straight away
back into the economy to do the thing to
create a youth economy that we like to
remember at Logan's Run did you ever see
that movie from the 70s a long time ago
great movie huh great movie had the over
35s overall shot so if you were over 35
you couldn't go out because you were so
ugly you're getting wrinkles and also
some things right so I think that
basically what we know to be serious
what we know is the lockdown will be
staggered in terms of who we LED at
first okay and we clearly can't let out
like my mom is 84 I go to visit her now
her generation have to be kept in
isolation for as long as it takes
okay because we we know what the data
tells us and then as you go down through
the population you get less and less and
less exposed or if you do get exposed
you actually can survive except for some
very very unusual cases and unfortunate
cases and ultimately there needs to be
some sense of national collective
immunity coming in so that we can
actually physically fight this ourselves
so it strikes me that the first way you
should do it is to release the under 35s
who don't live with their parents and I
know in Ireland and Britain that's a big
problem because many people in the
twenties in my generation obviously
didn't live with their parents but you
know that's the case to do but to the
extent that there is a sizable
population in Ireland and the
mathematics is about 70% of the end of
thirty fives are in employment and don't
live with their parents so and that's a
big chunk that's you know seven eight
hundred thousand people here I think the
UK and figures would be
multiply that by a factor of five six
whatever UK population is now I think
sixty-five million or something mmm is
it 60 million no it's always 16 it's
been over six dozen em for a while yeah
there's [ __ ] loads you so that's my
point is is and then they and then you
know what I find interesting Francis is
we're very happy to cede authorship at
to the youth in terms of music in art
and sport and lots of areas we don't
find it unusual that kids are making the
running are picking their 20s hmm so I
think that this idea that that that
there needs to be some sort headmaster
middle-aged headmaster in charge of the
economy it's kind of ludicrous so I'd
say let the match and do their thing and
also because it's it was a very
interesting thing as a thing an
economical scarring so scarring is what
happens and you see this in along the
children servants if in your twenties
you fall behind economically you never
ever recover your wages are never never
recover your status never recovers and
ultimately your entire world
economically is dictated by relative
failure in your twenties so it's called
scarring and you see this both in terms
of individuals but also you see it in
terms of generations so generate to
leave University for example our leave
college our commit to the education in
the midst of a recession actually do
considerably worse over the long term
generations who actually leave college
are leave school commit to the workforce
in a boom
this is a very interesting and it's got
to do with your sense of yourself now
you negotiate lots of issues so scarring
is something that we cannot risk this
generation who came into the labor force
during colvett are scarred forever
because of this the way in which you
actually militate against these ideas is
you release them early and let them do
their thing and do you think moving
forward now looking at Europe as a whole
do you think that the EU have handled
this crisis well number one and number
two the second part of this question is
do you think we're going to see the
collapse of the EU as a result of covert
as more and more countries your Italy's
you're Serbia's have less faith in the
EU well you've just strands has given me
the next Daily Telegraph editorial as
I've always said to clients of mine and
when I was working in investment banking
in the UK for many years I said them
look lads if you really want to lose
money the quickest way to lose money in
Europe is read The Daily Telegraph
because it's always wrong okay for the
Daily Telegraph David but thank you very
much for that well done David correct
you know I mean Constantin you know on
Europe it's always wrong yes always
wrong is because in general the English
upper class and their lackeys have never
really this go back to Agincourt this is
not to do it now this goes back to the
14th century I've never really got
simply when when edward ii defaulted of
the Medicis you know it goes back a long
way or the stuff i've never really got
europe and as always this sense that
europe is gone is Europe is one
iteration of crisis away from collapse
okay and here's there's the latest
example of that and my owns and of
course breaks it spices that particular
dish in a sort of a mental way but my
own particular fear is that easily is a
big it's a big problem because Italy if
you go back even to 1987 when you had a
large lira devaluation then let's not
give one even layer of devaluation that
93 evenly right evaluation you have
these periodic crises in Italy and it
hasn't been able to recover properly so
every time there's a crisis in Italy the
legacy is slightly higher unemployment
etc slightly bigger budget deficit and
poor Italians have been running a budget
but what people don't realize is that
Italy has been running a primary budget
circus so on the day-to-day basis it has
been running a spider circus for the
last 15 16 years which is extraordinary
and the problem is they've a legacy of
this massive over overlapped debt that
they took out in the 70s which frankly
should be written off I think and it may
well be at the end of this but
and you've got initially you've got the
house is read-only you're not fascist
party but Christ died fascist party
waiting in the wings okay and but my
sense is that the european union under
the european central bank has behaved
pretty well it has made a lot of money
available european politicians of course
have defaulted back onto traditional
line so you have the they called the
frugal for Austria Germany Netherlands
and Finland God knows why the Finns got
involved as a friend of mine said with
the exception of the Dutch and they were
four five three proper Nazi countries
Finland Austria Germany and the
calculator but I'm only joking right and
then in the other side the other side
you face you have the Catholics right
you've got us the Spaniards the
Portuguese the Italians right the
Catholics of the Irish and the under and
the Greeks of course who for a variety
of history and geography are an
exceptional case in in the context of
the European Union you know and you
mention Surya Serbs aren't in the
European Union yet and I would say
actually spoke to a Serbian made of mine
and not that lucky met her walking out
here on the pier that she's married to a
mate of mine and I said how are things
back home you know in Serbia she says
man we've gone through much worse than
this it disturbs the Serbs have gone
through and cause much worse than this
yeah and my sense is the European Union
will muddle through I don't think it's
gonna be an existential crisis I think
Germany and Holland particular land the
buckle of its on where there are not
they support the rest of Europe last
turns they had a big shindig at the
European Council nothing really happened
but that's the way Europe works it works
because two steps forward one step back
two steps forward one step back was at
the core of the European Union which I
think English people don't understand is
Germany and Germany does extremely well
after European Union in fact the
European Union click the eurozone allows
Germany to recycle its current account
circus
and that is exactly what it wants to do
and it will do that's what they
basically sell us Mercedes sometimes we
have money so that we don't then we
borrow money from them to buy their CDs
and periodically we default that's it
Elise reset the button I know what
you've seen in the brexit negotiations
was you know that basically what England
didn't understand a British not Britain
conservatives didn't understand was that
they were facing Germany across the
table nobody else and basically what
happened is Gunther just basically
squeezed the Brits and every time at the
negotiations and they just did to
squeeze them and said look you're a
small country if big notions based on
history you're not really at the races
we give you a deal but don't [ __ ] with
us and that's really what happened and
that's what's gonna happen this year as
well you don't think that that was kind
of how they treated Theresa May but
Boris Johnson is gonna be in a much
stronger position given his large
majority to to do better that's internal
politics I mean nobody cares in the rest
what what people in England don't suit
under says we don't give a [ __ ] whether
he's got a big majority or not right
that's that's your own internal dialogue
and that's fair enough you know I'm sure
most English people don't even know
who's in the Irish government right you
know these are who's in the French
government what's the actual makeup of
the National Assembly I'm sure most
English people have no idea what
coalition mrs. Merkel is on top of I'm
sure that right nobody cares about what
goes on in your own country no but my
point isn't that the external forces
care my point is that Teresa may had
lots of people sniping she wasn't able
to get rid of people in her own party
who were undermining her efforts with
Boris Johnson he made it very clear
you're either with me or you're out and
people have to sign up to his pledges
and now the Conservative Party at least
seems like they were speaking with one
voice under his leader
yeah but it doesn't make any difference
trade negotiations are about size right
the little fella gets destroyed because
they've nothing to bring to the table so
you know let's let's cut to the
chase half of the UK's trade with
imports and exports is with the European
Union not one tire it won't end there 20
percent half okay flip the other way
twelve percent of the e use traders with
the UK it's a it's a done deal
Britain will take whatever it gets and
if it behaves well it'll do well to get
a little bit better and if it doesn't
it'll go to WTO rules which are kind of
a disaster for for which is why you know
there has never been a situation where a
government goes into a trade negotiation
willingly in order to put up barriers
that's what's happening it's bonkers but
that's Briggs it's boring stuff you know
that's that's much more interesting I
mean you've brought up brakes and you
mentioned that we haven't talked about
it no no I just what I brought up was
that this idea that I see pedaled in the
British press mmm Europe is one crisis
away from catastrophe is something I've
seen since I was a kid here since the
1980s 1990s I've seen it with mrs.
Thatcher I see John Major I see them
through Tony Blair's periods I see what
Gordon Brown being against the euro all
that sort of stuff then of course I see
it Cameron I see it with Theresa May and
now I see it with Boris Johnson this is
a thing this is a this is a disease this
is a virus that is deep in the
Conservative Party nobody else has it
we're all the rest of us have the
vaccine euro scepticism right okay for
some reason there's a small population
in the UK that doesn't have the vaccine
and continues to show signs of as I said
the underlying conditions so you don't
think that with Germany because you are
a very very good article for the rest
times where you explained that you know
Germany is in real financial
difficulties their economy is not doing
well at all and the long-term prognosis
is pretty bleak you don't think that
will weaken them when it comes to having
a trade negotiation well I think no no
because
it's kind of relative right so we got
two sides of the trade thing you got the
trade side and this services site right
in in terms of trade the Germans are
very very strong still they make a lot
of stuff they make a lot of heavy stuff
they are heavily diversified around the
world in fact they make a lot of stuff
that Britain used to make like when I
was a kid the amount of cars in the road
here in Ireland made in Britain was
phenomenon us every second car you know
you'd pick up things and I remember even
my dad saying when he was a kid they see
everything was made in Britain and all
those things that were made in Britain
were increasing made in Germany and now
a lot of them are made in China so the
German big fear is that China will come
after the German car industry in the way
Germany would after the Italian car
industry which was something that
happened throughout the 1990s and into
the first decade of the naughties with
respect to Germany's overall position
the basic problem with Germany from
where I've seen is in a car as an
economist is that it doesn't like to
spend the money at earns okay the basic
problem with Britain is it like just
likes to spend other people's money
right because so Britain runs at a
current account deficit during a surface
you want to look at the two countries
and what could really help the Germans
is if they expanded their budget deficit
and began to spend money and in actual
fact if you've traveled in Germany
recently I did about a year ago I was
quite shocked actually you know my my
memory of Germany had been extraordinary
brilliant autobahns for example I drove
from Dublin to Croatia don't ask because
we have a dog and our children demanded
that I take the second dog so I drove
with the dog and anyway in the German
autobahns I was quite shocked by the BPO
they're not great Nick you know there's
a lot of love I have a lot of traffic on
the roads etc so it's very clear that
Germany could expand their budget
deficit quite dramatically if if they
wanted to but they really don't want to
so I think the dilemma in Germany is
twofold one is how they deal with China
and the second one is whether or not
they expand their budget deficit which
would actually limits dramatically some
of the conflicts at the heart of the EU
and interestingly I think the long-term
implication of covert on China is that
never ever ever again will any of us at
this summit including the UK and this
Germany France the United States ever be
dependent on China for essential
equipment I mean the idea of the Western
companies governments queuing up and
bidding with each other to buy little
bits of face masks and things that I've
shown that I will never happen again
and so I think the long-term implication
of all this is that the supply chain
management
that's so dominated global economics for
the last 20 years of which largely China
was at one end and the rest was were at
the other okay I think that's over I
think we're gonna see a huge amount of
on shoring back into the European Union
back into the United States maybe even
back into the United Kingdom now of
British companies particular some of the
big British pharmaceutical companies and
I think the reaction to this will be
that the alfresco globalization of the
last what 20 that's a since the fall of
the Berlin Wall and will be replaced by
more managed trade and I don't think
China will recover either its reputation
its brand or its assumption that
everybody will do business with China no
matter what I'm not too sure that's
gonna happen well that was that's been
one of the big issues that we've been
talking about a lot of people
particularly and I have noticed there
seems to be a correlation between being
kind of on the right of politics and
being a China hawk or a China critic I'm
among the center-left of politics yes
China but but you're also say
problematic data yes the matter because
you're not on the far left and you
probably don't have your pronouns on
your Twitter account and stuff like that
ruble with your own side but on the
China thing David it's I mean one of the
things that is becoming very clear is
that while none of the externalities of
doing business with China were visible
to us while we pretend the
the you know there's no cost to doing
business with China
everything was fine now suddenly people
are starting to realize and you know in
terms of the economic impact in terms of
the national security in fact also you
know we used to talk about China's human
rights record no one talked about
China's human rights record they're
talking about concentration camps now
those are very different ways of framing
the question yes yes yes I think that
look what we know is that pandemics have
lingering long term influences we spoke
about for example the trauma of the
pandemic flu pandemic but even if you go
further back you go to back to the
outbreak of the the plague in Marseille
in 1720 have profound impacts on the
French society currency collapsed
believe things and you didn't go back as
far as the the Black Death from Florence
and what happened thereafter was
actually a renaissance and huge
increases scientific inquiry in la la la
so these are profound effects my sense
is that after the Black Death for
example there was an extraordinary
increase in anti-jewish sentiment in
Europe it was phenomenal
brutality towards Jewish communities
because rumors were spread that Jewish
folk had I think poisoned the wells what
had actually happened was because the
Jewish folks had been get a wise by
Christians they didn't actually mixed
with Christians okay and therefore had a
slightly higher rate of they survived
more because think they weren't infected
because they didn't mix with the local
population so nothing to do but there
was a vicious vicious pogroms against
Jewish people and in the late 14th
century and those programs have really
ended with the expulsion of the Jewish
community from from Iberia where they'd
been there for a thousand years so you
have you have the historical evidence
that pandemic so for example Irish
people were blamed for being for typhus
in the United States there was an
outbreak of typhus in 1848 in New York
so cholera cholera and the Irish were
blamed and it was very much second
nature in in American circles to blame
the Irish as being carriers of cholera
but they've just happened to be poor and
poor people got this more than anyone
else so I do think that there will be a
material impact on China's brand from
this and I'm not sure that it will play
out how would the play of geopolitically
but what I am sure of is that it'll play
out in corporate boardrooms the idea is
do we want to be so exposed to that
country that says do we want a supply
chain to end in China where it might end
in Vietnam where it might end in
Thailand where it might end in some
other Asian country our and do we want
to be it's it's it's like the supply
line of an army do we want to be over
stretched and I think these are big big
issues and we have an addiction to and I
don't I use that word in its truest
sense to essentially cheap goods from
time from China whatever it may be and
it funds our lifestyle and we see that
absolutely and we all and we until now
we never questioned it do you think
we're going to enter a world where
people gonna be like you know what I
don't mind paying an extra tenner for an
electronic good as long as it's not made
in China and if it is I'm not touching
it well I'm not sure to me that extreme
mmm but I think that the corporate world
will change their perceptions of as I
said exposure to China I think I'm not
sure there will be a consumer boycott of
Chinese goods but the idea that China is
a neutral player in the world I think
has been badly affected by this
that's a mild understatement I think so
you know and it's interesting and that's
the funny thing about when we talk about
Europe etc but there's actually much
more that Bond's us together and
separates us in these perceptions that
the European Way
for want of a better word which is
shared by people in Dublin Manchester
London Sunderland Newcastle Marseille
you know Cologne there is a European
sensibility about the way we run our
societies our countries etc and as long
as we fight amongst each other we don't
see that with extraordinary similarities
I mean I think it was Freud described
the end of the austrian-hungarian empire
where the Czechs and the Slovaks and all
these characters he described as the
narcissism of small differences
nationalism and I actually do believe
that in the European British European
context that what would be narcissistic
about very small differences and one of
the may be enduring impacts of this will
be to wake us up to the fact or alert us
to the fact that you know we're doing
all this trade with China and maybe it's
not necessarily this sort of regime that
we should be opening our arms to all the
time and I think you'll see that
changing could the corporate world first
it's really interesting and in terms of
the China thing do you think that in
terms of the other changes as a result
from the current situation you talk
about nationalism obviously there's been
you know nationalism has been swept
through Europe in recent years and been
very successful do you think that this
will create more of that in the sense
that people start to question other
aspects of globalization we talk about
China and you know outsourcing all
manufacturing to China but there's also
you know immigration the people have
been very concerned about particularly
in this country for a long time and look
even as an immigrant the standard we've
had a very large wave of immigration
right so our people are gonna start to
question you know the the levels of
immigration into our Western societies
are we gonna start to talk about well do
we need free trade maybe we should just
make everything ourselves like all that
kind of stuff do you think that will
have a much there'll be a market shift
on those issues as well I suppose that's
was guys the the way the baby the best
way to look at all these big questions
is
whether or not there has been a
fundamental change in attitudes of
whether or not the pandemic simply
accelerates trends that we already see
yeah
and those trends that we already see as
he said her nationalism and
protectionism hey a sense of putting up
the barriers but we certainly see that
was in the in the United Kingdom and you
don't see them to such a huge extent in
the rest of Europe in fact the most
recent parliamentary elections have kind
of seen named trancing of those forces
but still it's in the ether you know
it's in the ether and what I would like
as a liberal and somebody who comes from
a country that has had a sort of
conversion to liberalism in the in later
life
is that I know what nationalism is all
about Irish people understand that
nationalism can lead you up a ridiculous
and very nasty and violent cul-de-sac so
we know what it's like it's not a game
for us it's not a sort of a something oh
let's let's let's infantilized politics
for a while and play with these little
sort of smoldering embers and see what
happens it's very dangerous
yeah but I do fear that the liberal
Western order has been badly damaged by
this virus and badly damaged by the
economic downturn now and the long-term
legacy of that unfortunately and are you
hopeful for the future David or do you
think we're gonna get into quite a
tricky period post covert if I can
please come back to where we started
Francis if the policy response is
radical now and what you notice always
in crisis is that what was radical
becomes mainstream what was mainstream
becomes redundant okay so if we try and
save our small business sector and with
the radical moves that I suggest that we
need I see the long term implications
being quite positive because I think we
will actually come out of this quite
quickly if on the other hand we let this
go on for a while and we follow covert
with austerity
and I think all bets are off and I
wouldn't be as optimistic but I'm a
great believer in that after having
tried all other alternatives we will do
the right thing eventually what a good
good note to end the interview on David
the last question we'll ask you is the
one we ask all our guests which is what
is the one thing that people aren't
talking about that we really should be
talking about as a society III think
that the the major change in all this in
kovat will be the change in people's
perceptions of what commuting is about
what working is about how our whole
relationship with consuming and
consumerism if you're looking for
exactly United States that online
shopping went up by 30 percent in a
month none of those people
this is food shopping food routine of
those people 50 percent so half of them
have never shopped for anything online
before now this is a big change this is
a massive change I think the way in
which large companies have been able to
keep working without any centralized
function with people working from home
profoundly changes the way in which we
will be community I think it's that time
to introduce things like road pricing
fur for traffic and traffic is basically
Road is real estate in in there in
Russia I wouldn't like to be in
commercial property I think that's been
profoundly overvalued I would like to be
exposed there and and so I think there's
a lot of stuff that we're not actually
talking as we're all talking about macro
economic stuff or politics but there's a
lot of micro stuff that will change
profanity as a result of this so I think
it's quite interesting that's very
interesting and who knows I mean that's
the one thing that my Eileen and I my
wife we keep talking about is like what
did you think some of these changes that
have come in now with people shopping
differently with people consuming less I
mean just in terms of our household
we've just found ourselves spending a
lot less money on stuff yeah us too
we're not spend I think these changes
are you know they in a way people demand
permission to change the behavior it's
quite interesting if you look at
psychology and whatever and kovat has
given us permission to entertain a
different way of living
and I'm not sure that that is going to
evaporate I think that that might have
some significant legacy fantastic David
well thank you so much for coming on
trigonometry I know what he wants to
check out your work where do they go to
follow you is this the David McWilliams
podcast it's on iTunes Spotify and all
the usual wherever you get your podcast
so it's the David McWilliams podcast
Uniqlo show guys
a pleasure to have new listeners okay
we'll get we'll send them all your way
thanks David whoo guys figure as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word